Kareem says, is it a bad idea to mention the contract on the video call before
the call? I typically don't because I don't want to like over make this a big
deal guys. Sales, as soon as people feel about buying pressure, then all of a
sudden they want to throw their hands up and they don't want, you know, they
want to do it. And so sometimes what happens is we start bringing stuff up
too quick. We start dropping price, we start dropping contract, we start
dropping this and that and the rest on our first call and we lose the deal.
I, sorry. Go ahead. I also, I never call it a contract. I say after he already
said he agrees, I say, okay, I'm going to send you this exclusivity agreement so
you know that I'm only working with you and it's going to stay that on there.
Like take it a lot, make it sound a lot more easy. Then I don't, I never say hey,
sign this contract for six months because that usually scares them. Yeah.
But if you do, it's all about how you say it, right? If you want to, sometimes
I'll say it. I don't care because I'm going to look and go, yeah, there's just
like, is there a contract? Yeah, of course. Obviously, like imagine, imagine
I'm committing to you exclusively. I'm not going to go look for any other
business owners, but you can just cancel anytime. That sounds like a one sided
marriage. That doesn't sound like it's going to work. Obviously, you need to
commit to me for six months. How are we going to judge this off one month? Like
I make it so obvious. Like, of course there's a contract, bro. Did you buy
your cell phone out right? No, of course you didn't. Did you buy your car right?
No, probably not. Just how it is. We do six month agreement, you know? So it
depends. Now you can phrase it whatever. It doesn't matter. And I like what you
say as well, Francesca, but you, if you're going to say it, be confident.
Yeah, of course. Of course there's a contract, bro. I mean, it's a one month
deal and you just freaking get a pick and choose and then go have tea and
crumpets. Come on, bro. You know?